seasons greetings gamespot gamers persia
here with our picks for the best gifts
to get for the playstation players on
your list this year
with a new console hitting story shelves
and recent revivals of franchise
favorites
there's something to get for gamers of
all ages so let's take a look
[Music]
god of war was one of our favorite
playstation exclusives this generation
and what better way to celebrate
kratos's
foray into fatherhood than getting your
hands on an art book detailing the
artistic direction behind the game
inside you'll find concept art early
screenshots of in-game footage
along with insightful notes about
development from various members of sony
santa monica studio after the smash hit
that was 2018's
spider-man from insomniac games
spider-man is back
although it might not be the spider-man
you remember in this launch title for
the ps5 that's also available on the ps4
players don the mask of miles morales
who gained his spidey abilities at the
end of the first game
there's new villains new powers and a
whole new section of new york to explore
but honestly the first thing i want to
do is just put on some music
and swing from the rooftops plus the
ultimate edition
includes a remastered version of the
original
the steel series arctis 1 is at the
intersection where price
meets quality if you want a headset
that's going to help you hear those
pesky buzzkills
answer calls on your pc or just listen
to some music
then you really can't go wrong with this
headset and the best part is
since it's bluetooth it will work on any
of your compatible gaming devices
if you're looking for a headset that's a
bit more in line with that
hulking white behemoth of a console the
size of your tv
it might be a good idea to pick up
sony's nextgen edition of their internal
headset line
the pulse 3d wireless headset with
built-in features that complement select
titles for the ps5 you'll be introduced
to the brand new world
of 3d audio with the launch of a new
console
now may be the time to finally set up
your own cozy little corner for gaming
that you've been dreaming of for years
and on top of that pledging allegiance
to your platform of choice has never
been more colorful
if you add in this awesome set of
playstation themed
lights representing the four buttons of
the controller
they run off of a micro usb or batteries
and can even react
to music you play so in other words you
can play
with your music this epic series is
headed to next gen with
the latest entry assassin's creed
valhalla
and i for one can't wait to stomp around
england with my motley crew of viking
friends
pillaging for loot valhalla will
introduce a brand new combat system
promising all new weapons and fighting
styles
and a giant beautiful world to explore
and if the return of the hidden blade is
any indication
a plot twist filled story connecting to
older titles is a good promise that
you'll be inside and away from the cold
this winter
2020 has been a very rough year and one
thing i know i'll be doing
is snuggling up with my favorite blanket
and sipping on some hot cocoa but persia
you say
what about my antique coffee table
that's been in my family since the ps1
i can't risk staining it well calm down
charlie brown because i've got the
perfect stocking stuffer
for you get yourself or your loved ones
their very own collection of these
adorable ps1 themed coffee coasters
this bundle comes with four coasters
featuring some classic ps1 games
and is sure to bring a tinge of
nostalgia to even the most salty gamers
among us
those are just a few of some of the
things we thought might be a good fit to
warm the hearts of your friends and
family this holiday season
be sure to check out our other lists for
nintendo xbox pc
and the entertainment fans in your life
and of course be sure to let us know in
the comments below
if you found something you think
deserves to be here stay safe and happy
holidays everyone